and sandy alcantara tows the slab for a
22nd time this season matching a career
high with six wins his last timeout that
was six plus innings against the
baltimore orioles faces the yankees for
the second time in his career of course
last year he ultimately was the
post-season clincher so anthony rizzo in
that top spot in the lineup it's a
looping
liner and caught behind short miguel
rojas makes the play here's a round of
applause for aaron judge who bats second
for the new york yankees this afternoon
swinging a miss strike three 99 miles an
hour from alcantara for his first
strikeout today joey gallo in left field
this afternoon here's the payoff pitch
swinging a mess got it 98 this time took
a little something off of it got judged
with 99 he backed off the fastball and
the yankees go in order marlins starting
lineup against this man making his 21st
start really good era the record does
not reflect how well he's pitched about
a strikeout period 34 walks and miguel
rojas has a lead off double for the
marlins here in the first and in scoring
position now for jazz chisholm jr
to fortify what boone has this is a
roller up the first base line and jazz
marlins are in business here early
they're on the corners with nobody out
now for brian anderson
and a ground ball to third backhanded by
wade spins and throws to first rizzo
makes the play in rbi for brian anderson
here is lewis brinson he's a right-hand
hitter a runner at second with two out
swing and a miss on the change
that'll do it norman's one run two hits
one man left we've played one gary
sanchez rugnet o'dore
torres four five six
and a ground ball on a hop to andy at
third
and there's one away
[Applause]
ground ball right side miggy row over
there with the shift gets it to first
and there's two way
here's the two-time all-star glamour
torres now
right back to sandy
underhand flip to aguilar back-to-back
one two three innings for alcantara
marlins leaded by one gardner-weight in
montgomery bottom third of the yankees
batting order the one-two pitch is in
there and called strike three that was a
good slider from alcantara and gardner's
down on strikes to start the third so
rizzo fortunately for the marlins oh for
one today sandy alcatra would love to
put an 0 for 2 ledger on there and he
may have here's a fly ball into center
field he did indeed sierra is underneath
it to make the catch
first pitch swinging anthony rizzo lofts
one to center field and the inning is
over quickly two outs here in the third
good time for jazz to run into one
jazz with a high fly ball rizzo
underneath it but he will give way no he
won't
that's a miscommunication right there i
had my eyes on rizzo he had his arms out
and then backed off
and i thought maybe torres was calling
him off but then torres got out of there
yeah a lot of i got it you take it kind
of going on here runner at first good
speed two men out bottom of the third
and the two on anderson
harner goes vote a second
[Music]
battle
he doesn't agree
gary's gonna wait to see if they
challenge chisholm seems convinced that
he's safe i don't know paul i think he's
safe
but the front foot went off and then if
the glove hit the back leg before the
foot gets there see the front foot does
beat the throw but then it comes off the
base
i gotta believe that he looks safe to me
and jazz is out i don't know anymore i i
it doesn't that's why he saw it's
happened to him a ton too here's aaron
judge to lead it off
crown ball base hit through the right
side for judd so the yankees have their
first end of the game
one away gary sanchez the ground ball to
anderson in his first time
there's been some of that in the game as
well
and then strikeout number five two way
here is room ned odor little shade right
there a miss for
odor another strikeout for sandy's got
six through four brian anderson he was
up when chisholm was thrown out stealing
swing and a miss
anderson down on strikes
now here is aguilar
swing and a miss two away
foreign for one today bounce back to
sandy in the second to end the inning oh
two pitch swinging a miss got him slider
up and away quickly now three pitches so
now tyler wade will bat
2-2 pitch swing and a miss strike three
got him with a slider inning over the
yankees go one two three in the fifth
we're halfway home this afternoon it's
one nothing miami brian de la cruz in
search of his first big league hit will
bat for the marlins one and two the
count to de la cruz here's the pitch
look at the line drive back up the
middle and the base hit
brian de la cruz has his first hit in
the major leagues leading off the bottom
of the fifth inning for the marlins yes
so now the game is rojas there are two
out second and third the one-two
swinging and a miss
got him on the curve and montgomery
works into and out of trouble craig
allen the pinch-hitter jordan
montgomery's afternoon is over the one
two is a foul tip and leon hung on to it
and there's one away strikeout for allen
there's aaron judge
nobody out and two out in the sixth
there's a strikeout it's number ten he
matches a season and career high 10
strikeouts for sandy alcantara
and here is jesus aguilar
oh what a play by wade fires the first
gets him he took an extra base hit away
from aguilar a beautiful play by tyler
wade a backhander down the line we'll go
to the seven
it'll be gallow sanchez and odor
and that one is drilled to right field
going back and playing it off the wall
as daley cruz and gallo gets himself his
first yankee hit well then a big hit
here to start off the seventh yankees
down a run but now the yankees stand to
not score here in the inning after the
lead off ringing double off the right
field wall by joey gallo labor torres
will bat this is miguel rojas who's got
a few baseball cards
in his own right great action shot there
by miggy and how about another seven
solid seven scoreless innings from sandy
alcandra so there is one away and that
will bring up giancarlo
roddy to third bubble
throw to first he throws it past andy
moving to third is gardner
the yankees catch a break
first and third with one man out in
comes richard bleyer to face anthony
rizzo
line drive up bases to left field and
that'll tie the score
gardner comes home it's a 1-1 game
and rizzo's first weekend as a yankee
continues to glimmer
[Applause]
here's judge and he lines a base hit to
left field
the throw home
is going to be not in time as stanton
scores and the yankees take a 2-1 lead
walk to rojas there's the tying run and
that'll bring up a left-hand hitter chas
gissam
that one is ripped to rizzo there's one
on the first
it's a double play
they double up the speedy chism and now
rizzo's just showing off two ounces
runner at first here's brett gardner
soft ground ball right side booted
booted again throw to third throws it
away
torres is coming home
and he will score the yankees lead three
to one and the yankees are one out away
from from sweeping
that one is lined to center field
gardner beck
makes the play and the yankees win three
to run
so princeton hit it well but gardner ran
it down and the yankees with a great
weekend in miami they beat the morelands
three in a row